alors Mathieu le problème c'est qu'il
m'a dit 4 fois ne pose pas de mauvaise
question
que tu veux non mais arrête mais il est
en train de me faire tomber avec
dépêche-toi tu nous as pas épargné
dépêche-toi est-ce que tu as déjà eu une
aventure avec une personne autour de ce
plateau non ben je te dis tout de suite
non non non non non même aucun
chroniqueur
mais je me souviens de rien
rien
quand j'étais bourré non non je regarde
les garçons sont pas à mon goût les
filles sont très belles tu sais quoi en
ce moment il a un petit crush sur
Delphine Wespiser
mais ça m'amuse
le délire à fond avec
je suis une américaine
lâchez-moi lâchez-moi là là oublie-moi
dans cette école Delphine tu la vois tu
me casses pas les couilles là mais
sérieux tu sais bébé la vie est courte
non non mais c'est pas top qui est